well video stores and those clerks with
encyclopedic movie knowledge are mostly
a thing of the past this year though the
last american video rental chain closed
its doors so some small independent
stores still exist and this month one of
them in the uk that specializes in an
old format expanded its inventory in a
big way the bbc's ian haslam has the
story
from liverpool
video odyssey in liverpool couldn't be
more retro if it tried and it seems
people can't get enough it's the same as
vinyl really where they were considered
obsolete they were
broken warm fuzzy things went wrong with
them but then after a while people like
that nostalgic feel the physical
connection to touching it putting it in
the machine and playing it you know
right now business is brisk it does give
me a little bit of nostalgia just just
holding them
and whatnot and seeing them the goonies
for example down there jurassic park all
family favorites
you're really chuffed with this aren't
you can i introduce you to this one as
well still water trout angler is that
float you bought we do get a constant
stream of 20 somethings coming into the
shop and saying wow this is amazing it's
like a little bit of time travel
and then you know they pick out things
oh look there's harry potter and many
more besides of course the old potential
pitfalls still apply my friend found um
a blue movie in the woods
watched it on his video recorder and
it'd been in the woods it all chewed up
and he had to dismantle his whole video
recorder very embarrassing in many ways
that's still a concern for people is it
well it is i mean i would recommend not
putting tapes that you find in the woods
straight into a player um but you know
one in a hundred one in a thousand might
chew up your machine but that's part of
the adventure in the journey you never
know do you look at this rocky iv of
course the whole process of watching the
video is a bit fiddly compared to how it
is today so you've got to whack that in
it's going all right press play
and there you go
and then it comes oh look at that
[Music]
we start this picture out andy i think
that might be one of the ones from the
woods mate
earlier this week andy's stock was
boosted significantly when he took
delivery of a huge video haul from a
garden shed in scotland that was bound
for landfill and this is what i came
back with 20 000 video tapes
whoa
i don't think we'll ever get offered a
collection that big again so i just
couldn't say no to it really you know
neither can vhs fans to get some popcorn
and have a nice time with the family
with my siblings watching old movies i
think it's great i can't stand looking
for a video on the internet but then
going into the shop was a whole
experience rewinding time might just be
the future
for cbs this morning saturday ian haslam
bbc news liverpool
that was awesome who's against popping
rocky foreign
question don't they degrade over time
yeah they do that's why you saw what it
looked like but i still have some that
are seem to be okay yeah i just don't
ever watch them
your old stories maybe with old stories
yeah yeah no dana's real
it's a fascinating watch trust me
next week on cbs this morning saturday